[Music]
hi everybody
um so today i am going to talk about
exploring intelligence and i'm very
excited to be here i wish
this was an in-person discussion but
i'll
try to keep you entertained in trying to
build smarter artificial intelligence
researchers often try to ape the brain
yet will brains and sophisticated ais
really be all that much alike today in a
two-part lecture
i'll explore this issue in part one um
i'll be discussing why the mind
is actually not a software program
so we often use language of computers
to discuss the brain we talk about
storing memories retrieving
information processing data and so on
but how far can we push the computer
analogy when it comes to really
understanding the nature of the mind
itself
is the mind really a software program
that's what i'll be talking about
in the first segment of today's
discussion
in part two i turn to an issue
that i develop extensively in my book
artificial you
the topic of the possible engineering of
conscious experience into artificial
intelligence so notice that
many people think that consciousness
is a sort of outgrowth of sophisticated
intelligence so
we see this in the biological arena for
example um
we're more confident in attributing
consciousness to ourselves
and to non-human animals that have
nervous systems
like us so for example you probably
think your dog
feels um or your cat feels
but um and in the biological arena the
more sophisticated the nervous system
is the greater our level of confidence
in attributing consciousness to it
now i suppose that this isn't a bad idea
i mean i'm far less confident thinking
that say a shrimp
is conscious maybe it has a little bit i
mean these are super deep
issues um but in any case what i want to
explore
in the context of a discussion of
artificial intelligence today
is the general question of the
relationship between
consciousness and intelligence um
i want to explore whether this sort of
generalization
that sophisticated systems um
sophisticated intelligent thinking
systems
are also conscious in the domain of ai
i want to call it to question not in the
domain of biology itself
so what i'll do is i'll discuss reasons
why sophisticated ai may not
turn out to be conscious so super
intelligent ai
may not have inner experience and i'll
explore
the general idea of what i call in my
book
consciousness engineering so
that's where we're going today so what
i'd like to do now is turn
to part one of the lecture and i'll
begin with a quote by the late stephen
hawking
he said that i think the brain is like a
program so it's theoretically possible
to copy the brain
to a computer and so provide
a form of life after death
well is that right that's what i want to
look at today
i'd like to start with an example to
kind of bring the issue home
um so we'll talk about a case which i
find
very intriguing as well as sad about
kim saosi um and i talk about this at
the beginning of chapter eight of my
book so i figured i'll just read a
little
excerpt for you one morning i awoke to a
call from a new york times reporter
she wanted to talk about kim sousy
a 23 year old who had just died of brain
cancer
a cognitive science major kim was
planning for graduate school in
neuroscience
in college kim and her boyfriend josh
had shared
a common passion for transhumanism
that's a philosophical movement and
cultural movement
that encourages the use of technology
for longevity and other
forms of enhancement when conventional
treatments failed
they turn to cryonics a medical
technique that uses
ultra cold temperatures to preserve the
brain upon
death kim and josh
hoped to make the specter of death a
temporary visitor
they were banking on the possibility
that her brain could be revived at some
point
in the distant future when there was a
cure for her cancer
and a means to revive cryonically frozen
brains crayonics is controversial
cryopreservation is employed in machines
in medicine
to maintain human embryos and animal
cells for as long as three decades
but when it comes to the brain
cryopreservation is still in its infancy
and it's unknown whether someone
cryopreserved using today's
incipient technology could ever be
revived but kim and josh had
weighed the pros and cons very carefully
sadly although kim herself would never
know this
her cryopreservation did not go smoothly
when the medical scans of her brain
arrived they revealed
that the cryoprotectant only reached the
outer portion of the brain
possibly due to vascular impairment
from stroke leaving the remainder
vulnerable to ice damage
given the damage the author of the new
york times
article amy harmon had called me to
consider the suggestion
that once uploading technology becomes
available
kim's brain could be uploaded to a
computer program
as she noted certain cryopreservation
efforts are turning to uploading as a
means of digitally preserving the
brain's
neural circuits harmon's point
was that uploading technology might
benefit kim
and more generally those patients whose
cryopreservation and illness may have
damaged too much of the brain
for biological revival the idea was that
in kim's case the damaged parts of her
brain could be
repaired digi digitally that is
the program that her brain was uploaded
to could include
algorithms carrying out computations
that the missing parts were supposed to
achieve
and this compute computer program
this was supposed to be kim well kim's
case
makes this abstract talk of radical
brain enhancements like
uploading so much more real
but her example illustrates that even
here on earth
these ideas are indeed altering lives
even if they
seem even if the examples seem
speculative
and hawking's earlier remarks voice and
understanding of the mind that is very
much in the air nowadays
the idea that the mind is a program the
new york times
piece for example reported that kim
herself
had the view that the mind is a program
okay so and you see in the picture
kim is uh putting a picture
on reddit um where the note says freeze
me read it
um so she did get the money uh
through her funding drive and and was
able to crowd preserve herself
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you